et bien aujourd'hui je voudrais que nous
puissions traiter quelques sujets de
politique intérieure et extérieure et
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à monsieur
su faire et à monsieur salbert de bien
vouloir m'interroger sur ces questions
de moi j'ai l'impression quand même que
la question de politique intérieure sont
plus importantes pour les français qui
sont davantage concernés par les
questions de politique intérieure dont
je pense qu'il est normal que ce soit me
suffire qui tire le premier nommé bien
si vous voulez même si une première
question si vous êtes élu
écoutez je vends le pardon monsieur su
faire de vous couper mais je voudrais
d'abord dire quelque chose sur un sujet
auquel je crois
il vaut mieux que je ne voulais pas être
en est que vous êtes journaliste
je voudrais dire un mot des changements
récents d'attitude de monsieur paul
monsieur poher nous avait dit que s'il
était candidat il abandonnerait
l'intérim
il l'a pas fait c'est une première
contradiction mafate
passons alors il nous dit maintenant que
s'il ne l'a pas fait c'est parce qu'ils
ne voulaient pas laisser l'intérim à ce
gouvernement que dit il il connaît ton
or j'ai lu dans la presse il ya trois
jours que monsieur poher président
dernier conseil des ministres avait
adressé ses félicitations et ses
remerciements à ce même gouvernement
alors je voudrais bien savoir quel est
le monsieur poher qui dit la vérité
de la même manière d'ailleurs il nous
dépeint le régime gaulliste et mes
années de gouvernement comme un régime
de terreur où tous les français vivaient
sous une emprise policière et sans avoir
la même la moindre liberté d'opinion
alors je me demande ce que faisait part
l'instant là monsieur poher qui était
sénateur et qui aurait pu dénoncer cette
abominable régime or je me suis
renseigné laisse moi je me suis
renseigné sur sa carrière et par exemple
en 1966 que croyez vous que monsieur
poher sénateurs a fait tout au long de
l'année 1966 eh bien il a déposé une
proposition de loi tendant à faciliter
la vente immobilière à tempérament
un point c'est tout en 1967 que
croyez-vous qu'il a fait il a déposé une
question orale relative la clinique
chirurgicale
athis mons dans l'essonne doute pas de
l'importance de cette clinique
chirurgicale
enfin si nous étions dans un régime de
terreur et que j'ai été parlementaire
j'aurais fait me semble-t-il davantage
en réalité en réalité il ya là quelque
chose qui n'est pas convenable qui ne
convient ni d'abord aux personnages que
voulait se donner monsieur poher de
réconciliation d'union des français nés
sur thoune et surtout aux débats qui
nous oppose
il s'agit de désigner le chef de l'état
et par conséquent pour les français de
choisir l'homme qui sera le plus capable
de diriger le pays de le représenter à
l'étranger et de protéger éventuellement
les français contre les difficultés
internes ou externes
alors ces attaques qui ne sont
d'ailleurs étayer docu l'argumentation
précise et bien quant à moi je n'y
répondrai pas alors je vous demande
pardon monsieur su faire de vous avoir
été rompues mais je tenais à dire ça
mais maintenant venons en à votre
question je suis sûr qu'elle sera ni
quand
en tout cas elle sera pas trop loin de
votre sujet il ya des gens qui depuis
onze ans sont dans l'opposition des non
communistes au niveau du parlement au
niveau de l'opinion publique au niveau
des conseillers généraux sont des gens
qui se sentent désir éthique et je me
demande si le général de gaulle d'une
certaine manière ne les a pas parfois
montré un peu du doigt d'une manière
excessive et ne les a contraints à un
espèce d'exil intérieur
peut-être que vous êtes dires de
monsieur power traduit-il ce sentiment
dans son comportement est ce que je
voulais vous demander est ce que vous
croyez que c'est une chose normale cette
espèce de sentiment de solitude d'exil
ou est ce que vous comptez ici d'y
mettre fin par des gestes de
réconciliation en 1958 vous savez
j'étais directeur du cabinet du général
de gaulle et quand monsieur guy mollet
madic
il le parti socialiste ne pourrait pas
participer au gouvernement qui allait
être formé après l'élection du général
de gaulle comme président de la
république je lui en ai dit mes regrets
en lui disant vous savez si le parti
socialiste se retire du gouvernement tôt
ou tard il va être amené à s'isoler et à
avoir être dans une attitude
d'opposition permanente et donc dans un
sentiment de solitude et par là même qui
crée un esprit de revanche
eh bien je voudrais pour ma part qu'on
sorte cet esprit de revanche que nous
sentons constamment nous l'avons sentie
en 62 au moment de l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel nous l'avons sentie en 65 au
moment de l'élection présidentielle
en 67 au moment des législatives le
dernier référendum et cette élection m
il faut des véritablement sortir de
cette espèce de d'ostracisme de coupure
le spa qui règne entre deux sortes
d'hommes politiques de sorte de famille
politique et il faudrait que tout le
monde accepte des institutions de la
vème république joue le jeu de la
cinquième république
à partir de ce moment là une opposition
la commission qu'elle existe entre nous
pas c'est à dire qu'elle se structure
vous avez c'est très difficile vous avez
vu que monsieur mauroy qui est le porte
parole actuelle du parti socialiste
débattent d'une part déclare qu'il faut
voter pour monsieur poher et 10 après ça
qu'il est l'ennemi du centrisme et qu'il
n'en veut à aucun prix
alors si ça part comme ça ça part mal
mais si une certaine opposition se
structurent ce se matérialisent et
participe aux débats parlementaires
participent à la vie politique
alors à ce moment là pour ma part je
suis tout près allait faciliter la tâche
et a essayé petit à petit de la mêlée
d'abord au travail parlementaire et
ultérieurement de préparer des
rapprochements
je crois que c'est même une nécessité de
qu'on ne remette pas en cause
perpétuellement en france le régime
politique pour la moindre crise alors
une question concrète là dessus est-ce
que vous utiliserez souvent la procédure
du vote bloqué monsieur su faire je ne
serai pas premier ministre n'est ce pas
de toute manière que je sois élu ou non
je ne serai pas
ministre il a les moyens de la faire du
vote bloqué est une question de premier
ministre et même souvent une question de
ministre souvent j'ai connu lé des
ministres qui dans la discussion
parlementaire croyait devoir user les
votes bloqués sans en avoir référé
c'était normal on ne peut pas suivre lac
de la discussion parlementaire heure par
heure
mais quant à moi andorre la discussion
budgétaire qui souvent demande le vote
bloqué et monsieur giscard d'estaing et
monsieur michel debré l'ont pratiqué à
égalité sur ce point et je suis sûr que
quel que soit le ministre des finances
demain il en aura le même besoin
d'ailleurs l'assemblée le comprend
andorre la discussion budgétaire
le vote bloqué doit être une procédure
tout à fait exceptionnel voilà mon avis
mais je répète
chacun son rôle vous devez avoir une
majorité au parlement
impressionnante près de 380 députés si
j'ai fait convenablement le calcul en
tenant compte des pdm rallier à bas il
ya deux ou trois jours manga les 370 une
relaxe à mort avec sa vente alors 380
c'est tellement vaste que votre
adversaire 10 d'une majorité le dit
méchamment qui va de monsieur tixier
vignancour à monsieur capitan c'est
extérieur qu'on n'est pas là semblait
encore et monsieur capitan lui y est
encore souvient comment est ce que vous
allez faire pour que cette majorité
fonctionne de manière convenable c'est à
dire qu'elles soient informés de vos
décisions de vos prises de position que
ne soient pas mises en fait du fait
accompli
qui sait peut-être un peu produits
autres auparavant c'est plus là aussi le
rôle du premier ministre que le rôle du
président de la république mais comme
vous
10 le rôle du président de la république
est certainement de poussé le premier
ministre à voir une certaine attitude
vis-à-vis du parlement au fond moi
j'avais une majorité très restreint et
par conséquent ma tendance comme premier
ministre était de discuter avec la
majorité avant le débat parlementaire de
façon à arriver au débat parlementaire
si je puis dire prémunit contre tout
incident du côté de ma majorité
parce que si j'avais eu des défections 4
juridique est de me trouver en
difficulté
la majorité tente infiniment plus large
et par conséquent permettant beaucoup
plus de souplesse
je crois que le rôle du gouvernement
sera certainement d'arriver dans le
débat avec plus de liberté et de façon à
permettre à l'opposition mais aussi à la
majorité au cours des débats de faire
valoir si besoin la demo besoin la
diversité de ses opinions car cette
majorité
ça n'est pas une majorité absolument
l'uniforme tout le monde ne pense pas
absolument la même chose donc je crois
qu'il y aura tout naturellement plus de
liberté dans les débats parlementaires
mais je souhaite néanmoins je souhaite
néanmoins que cette majorité s'organiser
vous savez que c'est ce que j'avais
essayé de faire que je n'ai pas toujours
réussi
n'est ce pas pour des raisons d'ailleurs
qui tenait à l'attitude de tel ou tel
leader qui depuis m'a rejoint
je crois qu'il faut que la majorité
s'organisent elles mêmes parce que le
premier ministre ne peut pas recevoir
tous les jours 3 180 députés
il faut donc qu'ils puissent parler avec
des représentants qualifiés et ses
représentants qualifiés engagent leur
goût donc il faut une organisation du
côté de la majorité plus de souplesse et
de liberté
du côté du gouverneur vous poser une
petite question économique
un journal économique à parier qu'elle
creuse quatre jours de l'éventualité
d'un emprunt d'un emprunt type inès vous
les 52 essentiellement pour permettre
aux capitaux qui sont un peu égaré au
delà des frontières de pouvoir rentrer
sans trop de difficultés cet emprunt
peut avoir des côtés un peu
ccif comme l'a eue l'emprunt pinay sur
le plan de la morale il peut être utile
sur le plan économique
est ce que vous êtes partisan telle
formule que coûte et ça il faudrait
d'abord que je connaisse bien la
situation financière est il mais ça
c'est certainement si je suis élu le
premier problème auquel je m'attaquerai
mais je vous dirais que là il y à deux
questions qu'il ne faut pas mélanger
il ya d'une part l'emprunt l'emprunt en
soi qui est une façon le gouvernement
ayant la confiance du pays de permettre
à l'état d'avoir des ressources et
éventuellement d'ailleurs de diminuer la
pression inflationniste spa en retirant
une partie de l'argent qui circule et en
le consacrant à l'épargné n'est ce pas
bien il ya une deuxième chose qui est si
ce que vous appelez l'aministie fiscale
au fond n'est-ce pas alors là c'est ce
qu'avait fait poincaré vous savez en
1926 c'est en effet ce qui a été fait si
je ne me trompe pas 1960 en 1950 deux
mais à mon sens nous ne sommes plus dans
ce cas ou si nous y sommes
ça serait pour des marges parce que les
capitaux qui ont fui à l'étranger et je
ne les approuve pas bien au contraire
bien au contraire
mais ces capitaux avait parfaitement le
droit de sortir cette fois ci il n'y
allait pas le contrôle des changes
après quoi on l'a établi mais on l'a
supprimée et ils sont ressortis par
conséquent ils sont sortis dans des
conditions qui moralement sont
condamnables mais qui juridiquement sont
sont parfaitement impeccable donc rien
ne les empêche de rentrer dès maintenant
emprunt ou pas empreintes croyez
vraiment qu'ils vont rentrer si
facilement que ça c'est capital écoutez
ce salbert demander leur demander leur
je crois vous savez que c'est avant tout
un problème de confiance car la
situation économique et même financière
de la france est solide il y a des
il y a des difficultés à l'indiscutable
il y aura des problèmes c'est certain
mais le fond est beau et si le
gouvernement inspire confiance
je crois que les capitaux rentrer au
marais est amusant c'est ce qu'on dit
aux etats unis c'est assez amusant
convient only fréquemment la presse
américaine la situation financière ces
suppressions économique de la france
dans le fond est bonne alors les
américains qui ont toujours une certaine
difficulté à comprendre ce qui se passe
en france n'est pas comprennent pas très
bien ce phénomène financier je crois que
côté américain on est prêt à vous aider
sincèrement pour toute mesure que vous
pourrez prendre toute décision pourrait
prendre justement pour faciliter ce
retour de capital noté si ou quand vous
rentrerez osé de jus dites leur de
l'aide alors ceci dit leur que s'il
avait dû comme nous 50 ans d'instabilité
politique et d'instabilité monétaire
il comprendrait probablement mieux cette
situation française qui demande un effet
beaucoup d'efforts pour être rétablie
sur une voie normale et sur une espèce
de stabilité dont nous avons
complètement perdu et l' usage et je
dirais même le souvenir soul n'oublie
pas que le franc n'a pas bougé entre
napoléon 1er et 1914 et depuis ce temps
là le support s'est engagé devant la
télévision à réintégrer les journalistes
licenciés il ya un an
alors je sais que vous avez répondu à un
hebdomadaire que c'était pas vous qui
aviez licenciés ces journalistes c'est
vrai je n'ai su pour rien mais vous
aurez peut-être les moyens d'aider un
gouvernement à prendre des décisions de
remise en ordre d'amnisty après kylie
d'amnesty sur l'algérie voyez vous je
trouve ça tout à l'heure vous me posez
des questions qui s'adressait au premier
ministre
maintenant il me semble que vous
adressez presque directeur général de la
rts
quant à moi ce que je pense le président
la république a beaucoup d'importance
sur un lit aux résines ab il a
énormément d'importance mais son
importance ne consiste pas engagé les
journalistes
rtf ni à les mettre dehors permettez moi
de vous dire que même comme premier
ministre j'ai en effet engagé aucun et
je les demande et je n'ai demandé à
personne qu'on en mettant à la porte va
vous savez à le rts en date pas
d'aujourd'hui je crois que tu n'aimes de
ce sale bella qui hélas a eu désolé
monsieur guy mollet autoroute reçoit
lille
cette rave exaucé meilleur de lui mais
pas avec moi jamais personne a eu avec
moi je n'ai jamais eu à me plaindre
quand à moi de personnes à la rtf et je
crois que tout le monde a le rtf le sait
pour le reste pour le reste je crois que
le vrai problème c'est le statut de
cette maison c'est l'organisation de
cette maison en qui à mon sens ne doit
pas tellement consisté à libéraliser
n'exagérons rien je ne crois pas que les
journalistes ici soit tellement enchaîné
en tout cas si j'étais à leur place et
qui sont enchaînés je m'en irai n'est ce
pas je crois surtout que la maison
manque de souplesse qu'elle est trop
lourde qu'elle est organisé trop
lourdement quel manque de souplesse et
qu'il faut la réorganiser complètement
de façon à y mettre à l'intérieur à la
fois plus de vivacité plus de
concurrence plus d'esprit de deux
concurrents cette compétitivité et en
même temps peut-être plus de liberté
plus de 2
ce que vous appelez ou ce qu'on appelle
si vous voulez la libéralisation je veux
dire par là le fait que chacun ait
l'impression d'être lui même devoir
s'exprimer librement
croyez pas qu'elle a besoin surtout de
stabilité cette maison à ces salles bea
d'un avis inverse
il voudrait que l'on ne touche à rien
moi je crois qu'il venait chez auchan
je crois mais il faut que la maison soit
d'un peu secoué et qu'elle se retrouve
elle-même dans la diversité dans la
concurrence et que c'est par là que ces
stores la véritable liberté quand on
peut se disputer avec le voisin qu'on
peut qu'on se sent concurrents du voisin
qu'on veut faire mieux que le voisin
eh bien ce sont alors les beaucoup plus
libre que si on est dans un système un
peu trop solennel et un peu trop
organisé dans ce qui veut dire par
concurrence eh ben je veux dire que je
ne vois vraiment pas pourquoi la
première et la deuxième chaîne par
exemple pour parler de la télévision ne
serait pas concurrentes au lieu des cils
s'adapter l'une à l'autre
je crois qu'il serait mieux qu'elles se
fassent concurrence et qu'elle cherche à
attirer les téléspectateurs
par exemple vous imposez échappé sept
ans vous savez c'est ça une dernière tf1
parce que finalement vous êtes quand
même une énigme pour les français
vous croyez pendant six ans vous avez
avancé masqué derrière le général de
gaulle
faïd était devant il était assez large
oui et puis au fond les pensées ont
commencé à vous voir à partir de mai
brusquement est apparue vraiment en
première ligne et finalement ils ne
servent pas très bien qui vous êtes
je crois qu'il ya une interrogation
quand on dit vous êtes un homme libéral
un peu radical
de la loire si on veut à partir de ce
moment là d'autres disent que vous êtes
peut être autoritaire et que finalement
il quelque chose de glace et dans votre
regard
et quand on dit inverse comme on l'a dit
à une certaine époque on pense mais non
monsieur pompidou c'est un homme au fond
de bon sens c'est l'auvergne ces
collines douces et on voit votre autre
aspect alors on ne sait pas et je vais
vous poser cette question sur un cap
précis par exemple l'université
vous êtes pour l'ordre vous êtes pour la
réforme
vous êtes pour que le lycée estienne
tranquille vous êtes pour le dialogue
dans les universités vous défendre les
humanités parce que normal tout de même
la latinité enfin c'est d'un monde
d'un autre côté vous êtes assez proche
du monde industriel et vous voudriez
l'université s'adapte au monde technique
alors finalement vous êtes avec qui dans
toute cette affaire je vous aime je
souhaiterais d'abord si vous permettez
que les téléspectateurs et
téléspectatrices les les électeurs et
les électrices qui nous regardent me dis
si j'ai vraiment le regard glacé alors
ensuite sur l'université puisque vous
prenez cet exemple je vous répondrais
très brièvement malheureusement il
faudrait désert je vous répondrai aussi
clairement que je vais le pouvoir d'une
part par ma formation et peut-être aussi
par mon tempérament je suis partisan de
ce qu'on appelle la culture générale et
je crois que le temps de ce qu'on
appelle les humanités n'est pas fini par
contre je ne crois pas que
l'enseignement est pour but de former
des
des bourgeois comme au 19ème siècle qui
lisent virgile n'est ce pas
à livre ouvert on s'adresse maintenant à
tout le monde et il faut aussi que
l'université mène un métier et par
conséquent il faut qu'elle soit ouverte
sur le monde extérieur sur le monde
économique et sur l'évolution de ce il
faut donc à la fois garder la culture et
s'adapter au monde moderne
il y à une réforme en cours qui
commencent plus exactement qui commence
d'ailleurs avec quelques grincements
comme tous les commencements je suis
partisan d'une réforme profonde des
méthodes et des gestions d'université je
suis partisan de l'autonomie des
universités et à ce pont du las je vais
plus loin que la loi d'orientation et
d'ailleurs c'est normal puisque la loi
d'orientation ne fait que donner
l'indication d'une direction et je vais
donc plus loin mais je ne crois pas
d'autre part que cette réforme gagne à
se dérouler dans le désordre
je crois que s'il faut que les
enseignants les étudiants et tout le
monde participe à la création à la
gestion à la conception même de cette
université nouvelle
une fois qu'ils ont admis un minimum de
règles il faut qu'il respecte ses règles
que les maîtres puisse enseigner être
respectés sans être obligé de se frayer
presque le chemin jusqu'à leur chair la
force des poignets devant et que leur
autorité soit naturellement reconnu et
que les règles admises soit admise par
tout le monde et swap respect autrement
dit il faut de l'autorité pour permettre
la liberté de s'exerce que comme c'était
déjà dit la déclaration des droits de
l'homme la liberté ça consiste à pouvoir
user de tous ses droits sans nuire à
autre et c'est au moment où on commence
à nuire à autrui consorts de la liberté
alors vous me direz concilier la culture
générale et l'adaptation au monde
moderne
concilier l'orb et l'autorité la liberté
tout ça c'est difficile
parfaitement ces défis et non seulement
c'est l'objectif que nous devons
atteindre mais à mon sens c'est la
vocation de la france
la vocation de la france c'est de
concilier une espèce de tradition dont
elle est détentrice était une tradition
profonde ancien européenne et puis
l'adaptation au monde moderne et à ce
monde que les états unis en particulier
sont en train de forger et qui nous
demande à nous français un effort de
compréhension et d'adaptation difficile
c'est cette conciliation nous devons
réaliser c'est difficile il serait plus
facile de tomber dans un âge dans un
extrême ou dans l'autre mais l'objectif
c'est le milieu et pour ma part c'est ce
que je chercherai à aider mon pays à
atteindre vu quand je vous écoute parler
c'est l'impression d'entendre indigne
d'universités américaines
car comme le problème d'étudiants comme
vous savez ne sont pas uniquement
français et internationaux dans le fond
tout a commencé en amérique vous tenez
des raisonnements qui sont exactement ce
que tiennent dans le fond les ledeen les
responsables des universités américaines
en difficulté de trouver justement cette
conciliation entre scène c'est tendance
oui vous savez il faut pas non plus
tomber dans l'extrême tiko 6 à 6 plaute
ise sur une genèse qui a 20 ans et qui
refuse la société de consommation et qui
est incapable ou se déclare incapable de
vivre dans la société moderne
il ya là du romantisme et à 20 ans ne
nous sommes tous dans tous été
romantique
ils ont tous rejeté le monde nous
vivions quitte ensuite à nous y adapter
grâce au ciel mais en apportant à chaque
fois un peu de renouveau c'est le propre
de la jeunesse
donc ce n'est pas simplement la jeunesse
qui a du mal à s'adapter c'est tout le
monde tout le monde a du mal à s'adapter
à ce monde en mutation permanente en
changement perpétuel et je connais
beaucoup de gens qui sont beaucoup plus
malheureux que les jeunes étudiants
de ce point de vue là mais ça ne
m'empêche pas de comprendre le point de
vue de certains jeunes étudiants et aux
fonds d'avoir une faiblesse pour eux
mais je ne veux pas qu'ils empêchent
leurs camarades de travailler et je
voudrais les décider eux-mêmes à
comprendre que leur intérêt c'est
finalement eux aussi d'apprendre quelque
chose et de s'adapter à la vie on ne
refait pas la vie il faut s'y adapter
surtout si on veut la modifier c'est la
fin mai
les frontières c'est ça l'accord ge
pensent que vous surprendra pas c'est ma
première question concerne les relations
franco-américaines m6 relations n'ont
pas toujours été excellentes vous le
savez très bien ils ont même été
difficile elle s'améliore depuis un
certain temps depuis que monsieur nixon
était à la maison blanche
est-ce que vous pensez que
l'amélioration des relations franco
américaines doit être le point principal
ou tout au moins l'un des points
principaux de notre politique étrangère
écoutez je me suis félicité pour ma part
de l'amélioration qui a eu lieu dans ces
derniers mois des relations entre la
france et les états unis
je crois que ça tient d'ailleurs pour
une bonne part à deux choses l'une
c'est l'évolution de la situation au
vietnam et l'autre c'est que le
gouvernement des états unis et en
particulier d'ailleurs me semble t'il le
gouvernement monsieur nixon a mieux
compris que la france 1 reprenant
quelque sorte sa liberté vis-à-vis de
l'organisation technique de la noc l'on
appelle l'otan n'avait pas moins gardé
sa fidélité profonde à l'alliance
atlantique et autres étaient de
l'alliance atlantique
et puis au surplus ce monsieur nixon
s'est rendu compte que la france et les
français gardent et aux états unis aux
américains cette vieille amitié qui date
maintenant de la fondation même des
états unis
alors je crois à l'amélioration de leur
apport de façon permanente et pour ma
part je suis tout prêt à y travailler
c'est parler de l'aube temps justement
il est évident que si nous voulons
reprendre avec les américains des
relations très amicales c'est ce que
nous avions autrefois il va falloir
assoupir tout de même probablement un
certain nombre de positions nous avons
prises je ne sais pas ce que vous
appelez assouplir les les positions j'ai
dit et je répétais que je cause avec la
france devait rester dans l'alliance
atlantique mais
dit aussi et je répète qu'il n'est pas
question pour nous de nous intégrer à
nouveau dans la machine dite de l'otan
je répèterai encore une fois ce qui a
été dit à l'époque je prends la sphère
de cubage a choisi parce que c'est une
affaire où le général de gaulle a
approuvé la position du gouvernement des
états unis est bien la sphère de cuba
éclater le président des états unis a
pris sans nous consulter sans consulter
ses alliés un certain nombre de
décisions
ces décisions pouvaient entraîner une
guerre entre la russie et les etats-unis
et nous français par exemple ou
européens nous nous trouvions engagés
dans cette guerre même si nous ne
l'avions pas voulu par la présence sur
notre sol de troupes et d'un tout un
système d'armes américains et bien c'est
cette liberté que j'ai là le vol a donné
à la france que pour ma part j'entends
parfaitement sauvegarder mais ça
n'enlève rien à l'esprit de l'alliance à
l'esprit de l'amitié et au fait que dans
le cadre de cette alliance est dans les
limites de cette alliance nous serions
le cas échéant aux côtés des états unis
si l'alliance s'étaient manifestement
concernés quand je pense à un
assouplissement de certaines positions
je pense également problème européen je
pense si vous voulez au problème de la
grande-bretagne et du marché commun vous
avez dit à plusieurs fois que vous que
vous souhaitiez à plusieurs reprises que
vous souhaitiez que l'on crée un espèce
de système européen occar à votre guise
participer ce qui lui donnerait du reste
plus pure plus de force
comment voyez-vous par exemple la
participation de la grande-bretagne à un
système européen quelconque est ce que
vous pensez qu'on peut en rester au
marché commun ou faut-il changer les
règles du club
faut-il concevoir quelque chose de
nouveau écoutez ça ça dépend
ça ne va pas de nous ça dépend pas que
de ça dépend d'abord de nos partenaires
ça dépend aussi des la grande bretagne
on peut imaginer plusieurs solutions on
peut imaginer que la grande bretagne
entre dans le marché commun et en
accepte les règles purement et
simplement penser que c'est possible
pour ma part je crois qu'elle y aurait
beaucoup de mal mais enfin rien n'est
exclu du moins c'est ce qu'elle prétend
il ya une deuxième solution qui veut que
la grande bretagne viennent rejoindre
les six avec cinq ou six autres pays à
partir de ce moment là alors je le dis
très franchement ça n'est plus la même
chose on ne fera pas une communauté à 12
ou à 13 fonctionnant comme fonctionne la
communauté ainsi ce qui a déjà beaucoup
de mal fonctionner beaucoup de mal c'est
très difficile de faire marcher six pays
exactement du même pas en fermage 2013
c'est exclu alors il est probable qu'à
ce moment là il faudrait repenser
l'ensemble du problème et qu'il faudrait
construire quelque chose de nouveau et
ce que j'ai toujours dit qui est vrai
c'est que si ce quelque chose de nouveau
doit être repensée nous français nous
n'y sommes pas opposés par principe mais
à une condition bien entendu c'est que
sa garde à la france les droits et
prérogatives qu'elle a dans le marché
commun je pense surtout aux intérêts de
notre agriculture est ce que vous pensez
tout de même par exemple que les
relations spéciales qui existait entre
paris et bonn au cours des dernières
années sont également l'une des pierres
de base la politique française enfin et
bien vous savez j'ai dit à mulhouse où
j'ai parlé de ses problèmes de politique
extérieure que la réconciliation
franco-allemande et la coopération
franco allemande devait être exemple est
assez à dire servir d'exemple mais pas
privilégiée
quand vous voyez où les relations avec
la russie exactement dans la même ligne
actuellement
est ce que nous pensions que la fierté
des slovaques a changé un peu la
perspective du rapprochement avec
l'europe communiste la sphère tchèque
n'est ce pas pour nous a été moralement
tout à fait douloureuse vous en doutez
et d'autre part elle a montré la
difficulté qu'il y avait même à mes yeux
l'impossibilité qu'il y a à faire
coïncider système libéral avec le régime
économique communiste et elle a montré
en même temps que la politique des blocs
n'était pas morte à l'est non plus bien
sûr mais elle mêle sera donc elle a donc
certainement été une cause de
ralentissement dans l'évolution de l'est
européen et à ce titre là aussi je le
déplore et non pas simplement pour les
tchèques
mais ceci étant dit c'est l'intérêt
permanent de la france et de la russie
que de se rapprocher le plus possible et
de coopérer le plus possible c'est à
l'intérêt que l'histoire la rd montre
depuis très longtemps et puis surtout
c'est l'intérêt de la france d'éviter
que la politique des blocs conduisent à
un conflit entre le bloc occidental est
le bloc oriental conflit qui serait
fatal si on continue à vivre dans une
atmosphère de guerre froide et le rôle
de la france là aussi là aussi je su
faire c'est d'être les passifs puis dire
d'essayer de concilier des extrêmes de
rapprocher des extrêmes de rapprocher
l'est et l'ouest
voilà pourquoi sur ce point je persévère
dans la politique qui a été menée par la
france depuis ces dernières années